you know i've been lucky enough to be
nominated in the uh music event category
uh for the acms i think a few times over
the years i don't know how many times
i've had a lot of duets and
and and some of them have been nominated
i even
one i think my very first acm award
ever was um my collaboration i did with
trace atkins
for hillbilly bone and uh
and and hopefully tracy won't hear this
but winning that award with him doesn't
mean
is nearly as much to me as just being
nominated for that award
with with gwen because you know uh
gwen is she's my she's everything to me
and
to be able to to make records with her
and and uh and have a couple of hit
songs with her out on country radio and
to have that
recognition from uh the acms
that you know that that somehow just
takes it to another level not for me but
for gwen because
uh it's not something that i think she
ever
thought was possible for her and in in
her career and her music and in her life
really uh
you know it's it's strange enough that
she and i are together
to begin with let's be honest but the
fact that we're making records together
and now we're nominated for an acm award
uh it's just unbelievable and and just
so happy about it
2021 is marks the 20th anniversary of
the release of austin and and it's climb
up the charts and
and so for my acm performance this year
i'll be
i've been given the opportunity to
perform austin in
in honor of its 20 years and uh
and i'm so happy about it and uh
it's just that song has just given me
every opportunity and music and in my
career that
a song can give somebody when it came
out it was such a huge record at the
time and i was an unknown artist that
you know it really came out of nowhere
and and the song was actually so big it
was hard to recover from it for a little
while
uh as far as trying to get momentum back
at radio you're always
you know you're you're compared to to
what you did last time
when when you have a song as big as
austin you know it was a struggle for us
but we were finally able to get on track
and now here we are 20 years later
and we're going to also be performing
minimum wage which is my current single
that i have
out and it's just a great opportunity
that acm has
given me uh and allowing me to
uh recognize this this mile marker in in
my career
and and that's valuable time on this
television show and on this stage and
and it's really cool that they're that
they're allowing me to to celebrate 20
years of that song
you know there's going to be a lot of
great performances like always on this
year's acm awards
uh and and a lot of these artists are
people that i've known since
they were baby artists you know and now
they're huge stars like
dan and shea and there's there's
literally a list of them that
are going to be on the show and they've
all gone on to be superstars and it's
really cool
on one hand to to see uh
that happen for these young artists that
i've known since they were
kids and then also to still be in the
mix with them you know that's also
a cool thing